ce que vous allez bien beau les choses
soient claires entre nous vous aviez le
choix aller en soirée vous regardez la
vidéo de squeeze bonne soirée
aujourd'hui on est sur house party c'est
un jeu en 2d qui est finalement
simulateur de gros soirée américaine à
base de gobelets américains à base de
filles à base de grosses villas
habillez-vous bien les amis car ce soir
on va peut-être pécho alors va parler à
madison pour commencer ouais ben et make
a pas de soucis madison où es-tu il ya
du bon sens ici il ya une ambiance où on
va particulière certes mais une ambiance
bonjour madison est ce que tu es madison
1 est ce que je te connais non mais
j'aimerais qu'on se connaisse un petit
peu mieux en ce mignon je suis madison
cemaf fait heureuse de te rencontrer
aulas mais sur un événement madison et
les verts
ok peut-être parce que cette femme
n'arrête pas de serre à table basse avec
ces [ __ ] de tongs
mais quelle dose comme du caire de
posséder
et bonjour toi salut je suis ashley je
suis la soeur de madison heureuse de te
rencontrer beaucoup tvm quoi c'est
devait leur compte manger rien fait
encore que je suis juste venu à la fête
j'ai amené ma petite bouteille de coca
comme ça pour être bien vu du coca parce
que nous tiennent à col c'est trop cher
donc j'ai quand même ramené un truc tu
es la soeur de madison
je n'aurais jamais deviné tué bien plus
belle qu'elle est une bonne réponse ddp
ça très bien alors pasqua au merci c'est
vraiment mignon elle est contente
[ __ ] déjà elle aime sa soeur c'est ça
qui fait plaisir qu'est ce qui se passe
entre tous et madison a donc et une
embrouille un jour en sortant de la
douche je me suis aperçu qu'il m'avait
volé tous mes vêtements et mes
serviettes et j'ai dû courir à poil à
traire toute la maison oh ma pauvre
magnusson
ashley bardon bon étoiles à fontenay qui
a pas de danse et talent groove des
chiottes sur la transpi pont peut pas
sortir ce jeu vidéo mais tendance est
comme ça depuis une heure tu sors la
transpi forcément ma bonne dame
stéphanie c'est triste que personne aux
eaux qui se battent
qu'est ce qui se passe un guet-apens aux
mondiaux bon ok tu es qui les choses
soient claires on va boire un verre au
nom fera the losers phrase de losers
j'adore tes lunettes
tu as l'air intelligent tu as donc s'y
est pas du net je ressemblerais juste
une petite [ __ ] la meuf comme les gens
la défense et on est tombés sur une
poule la meuf est à temps elle va pas du
tout bien quoi elle me tourne le dos aux
caisses comment je peux rattraper le
coup
j'arrête pas de te voir il ya eu au
téléphone tout va bien elle je vais
demander ça te regarde pas ok oh là là
mais les jo mais [ __ ] qu'est ce que tu
penses de stéphanie tu as plus de choses
sortir avec elle ce soir qu'avec moi
enfin ouais mais c'est fini c'est pas
trop mon genre
elle et elle est gentille mais ce patron
brasier mais qu'on va voir ce cadeau
dans cette maison parce que là ça c'est
la dépression oh mon dieu l'homme stocks
qui surveille la bouteille de whisky
comment ça va mais quand t'es pas bourré
toi non pourquoi cool parce que j'adore
défoncé le cul des mecs bourrés jay
absolue que c'est mon devoir de citoyen
de les défoncer c'est ma contribution
pour rendre ce monde meilleur et
d'autres moyens pour le on est un manga
donc lui si je bois il va me défoncer
clairement il va me défoncer au je peux
le dire je suis bourré gens que j'ai vus
tout choc vase il va embrouiller tu es
mort connard quoi david à tanger une
technique peut-être que la transpi de
cette femme va mettre tes mal et va
quitter la pièce
quoi hall pata ok je l' approche plus
globale est en toi t'es mort etc rodez
puta alors tu es qui bonjour je n'arrive
pas à quoi qu'on se rencontre enfin je
suis rachat elle content de te
rencontrer rafael j'adore ton pull aux
ce vieux truc va merci c'est mignon a de
fait lorsqu'il a acheté hier à mersch
qui arrête arrête on connaît au tessin
screamer ce mec mais t'approche pas
comme ça quand tu parles mais qu'est ce
que je peux faire pour t'aider
j'ai hyper mal au crâne est ce que tu
peux avoir de l'aspirine ok ok aïe aïe
wild au départ mon dieu il remonte avec
sa bouteille à la main mais qu'ils
arrêtent de boire si tu veux un jour
aller mieux et ça va quoi et j'ai vu
patrick m'a détruit ont cependant je
pense qu'ils en train de voler des trucs
watts le connard je reviens au maire
j'ai créé une embrouille j'irai une
embrouille au une grande salle de bain
de lui prendre peut-être en modules un
téléphone nouvelles quêtes c'est le
téléphone de madison faut que je lui
rende je vais lui rendre son problème
tout cas toujours pas d'aspirine pour
notre ami jean michel pm bon mec ce
concept compliqué là ok t'es mais qu'est
ce qu'elle veut
puisqu'elle en train de faire oh là là
non elle veut se confesser on ne fait
pas le coup de la mode qui me freine
zone en me racontant les problèmes
qu'elle a avec son ex non non non non
ont boudé yann clay c'est avec les de
quoi bathroom skeleton cake canopen eni
bathroom haut on va rentrer sont elles à
madison a laissé coi doit pas chercher
midi à 12 heures ça ne veut rien dire
tiens omg est un très bon téléphone
merci beaucoup
inquiète c'est normal est ce que je
prévois de récompenses qui sera rendu
ton téléphone genre un petit bisou ou un
truc du genre
alors on va sauvegarder ol a dit aide
moi à faire une blague à ma soeur et y
aura plus qu un bisou qui tu attendras
olabe atlantique a pu faire ça
ok c'est parti comment on fait j'ai déjà
fait tomber accidentellement de la bière
sur ashley j'ai verrouillé mon arme à
redon qu'elle pourra pas aller chercher
des affaires pour se changer mon plan
est d'abord de lui faire croire que sa
seule option c'est de descendre en bas
et de laver ses vêtements quand on aura
ses vêtements dans la machine alors on
aura juste à la forcer à sortir et à se
balader à poil dans la maison au milieu
de nos invités par l'ats hasni obtient
sa confiance pour qu'elle te füle ses
vêtements et que tu puisses les laver
hockey belge est la clé de la salle de
mahomet c'est horrible ce qu'on fait
alors elle est où elle est la mecque
on est les pires on est les pires
comment je peux faire pour la confiance
meuf salut ça va ça lui aimerait ça va
tu as l'air un peu distrait twem akom ii
sera renversée savent lire sur moi et là
je suis tout mouillé donc j'ai besoin de
trouver un moyen de me sécher je peux
t'aider pour ça tu sais où tu veux bien
m'aider j'ai besoin de sécher ses
vêtements peu importe comment alors
attends faut qu'on trouve une serviette
de balma pour s'essuyer [ __ ] mais qu
on est en train de faire du boulet on
attend tous les mecs fait des dons au
contraire seulement hélas dans ce jeu
vidéo il ya du bowling très bientôt je
trouve un truc pour l'assécher mékong
fait duper la yes aller au parfait merci
mais les vêtements reste salée il pue la
bière je peux les laver pour toi si tu
veux tu ferais ça pour moi attention
quand je vois que tout ça ne fait pas
partie du plan de madison
je ne sais pas encore si je peux te
faire confiance aux [ __ ] là mais je
dois gagner sa confiance madison un
journal intime elle ne laisse personne
le lire si tu peux me l'a menée alors je
saurai que je peux te faire confiance
ok vous avez oublié son [ __ ] journal
intime de merde je sais parfaitement où
il est il est là c'est évident il est là
et aurait et foi est une [ __ ] de
psychopathe pour mettre son jean arthuis
dans un coffre fort à temps et si je
vais il ya vraiment un problème avec ce
pantalon et ses chevilles meuf vraiment
aux rita 4 jan o je veux pas
on s'en va on va jouer avec les copains
à la maison
well well well les amis après quelques
recherches j'ai vu qu'il nous faut un
papier un stylo où on peut trouver un
papier un stylo c'est ça la vraie
question non pas une meuf qui dansent
bizarrement vraiment des papiers un silo
à wil à obala aux mecs dans la chambre
me souviens la lie à du papier the
whispered tech
voilà je suis refait et on veut utiliser
le haut fait d'armé qui grattent s'ils
sont contraints tableau l' horrible
bref le code est apparue en gros elle
avait marqué le code sur la peinture de
slip qui est là et puis elle avait
effacé mais bon grâce à une merveille de
technologie ne regarde pas comme ça 36
24 36 c'est bon c'est son [ __ ] journal
ashley vient laver et je vais dérivant
vers aix vrai j'ai le journal intime de
danseurs impressionnant je pensais pas
que tu le ferais le journal contient
tous les mots de passe de madison what
the fuck
tiens voici le code de son téléphone
alors je peux aller partout manon
facebook email en salle est incroyable
bon ben je t'aide à sécher tes fringues
ou quoi ok six mois on va aller se fait
dans un endroit où je pourrai me changer
ok ok darling miss you i'm with you make
me dream make my dreams la queue prins
ok on dirait bien qu'on est seul donne
moi tes fringues et je vais laver tout
ça allez vas-y
est ce que tu peux fermer la porte avant
au oui pardon excusez moi voilà
c'était quoi le plan déjà j'ai oublié le
plan j'ai oublié plus avec ces conneries
je perds ma part je n'appartiens à
personne de faire au pardon quoi c'est
quoi ce rire schizophrène go donc là je
crois qu'il faut que je les lave là
dedans
voilà est-ce qu'on fait nos bâtard genre
on garde les vêtements et on va les
donner à sa soeur ou est-ce qu'on fait
pas nos batailles on lui rend ses
vêtements je sais pas tant un mec je
sauvegarde va faire les deux favoris
steak
elle va bien longtemps labeouf elle
attend calmement à poil dans une jambe
n'importe quoi où il ya ce jeu c'est
interminable j'espère au moins que ça
vaut le coup c'est un bon point qui
désavouent le coup c'est pour que
derrière elle nous freine zone savall
hausse et finit au kg les vêtements je
vais pouvoir lui rende la sacer elle
croit trop que j'ai eu à mener les
fringues et ben non ok tiens tes
vêtements
oh merci beaucoup tu viens de me sauver
la vie n'hésite pas à me donner c'est a
besoin de quoi que ce soit vu que t'es
sauvé la vie qu'est ce que tu viens de
me faire une pub pour moi mercier jeu
sam c'est dérangeant quand même là d'en
arriver là je on arrête tout alerte aux
jaloux mais qu'il faut faire en fait un
press p pour sortir ton pénis
non mais c'est quoi ce jeu en fait à à
précsé après fois que je rougis dans une
vidéo je rougis pour de vrai et voilà ce
n'est pas un média aussi ça vous a plu
c'est pas c'est parti en couille ce jeu
est allé trop loin il est on va pas ce
mythe aux abois là on a choisi de rendre
un service plutôt que de boulahia
quelqu'un mais on méritait pas ça mais
j'ai même pas envie de voir l'autre fin
on en a vu assez on en a vu assez
suite à ces évènements mon innocence et
profondément brisé pour laisser place à
la perversion hausse de révision
prochaine adversaire regarder portez
vous bien désolé c'est a choqué des gens
la fin du jeu c'est je pense pas que
c'est allé loin comme ç'a vraiment été
cités choqué l'homme elle est attendue
prochainement portez vous bien le tour
du monde
[Musique]
ça